let's jump into the first story from cnn
business you know we love cnn we do cnn
reports elon musk threatens to walk away
from twitter deal interesting choice of
headline depend uh based on what the
story is it's a lot bigger than that
they say elon musk issued his most
direct threat yet to walk away from his
purchase of twitter on monday openly
accusing the social media company of
breaching the merger agreement by not
providing the data he has requested on
spam and fake accounts
in a letter to twitter's head of legal
policy and trust vijayagare musk alleged
that twitter is actively resisting and
thwarting his information rights as
outlined in the deal this is a clear
material breach of twitter's obligations
under the merger agreement
and mr musk reserves all rights
resulting there from including his right
not to consummate the transaction and
his right to terminate the merger
agreement
now twitter apparently issued a response
saying that they have been very uh very
cooperative in sharing information as
per the terms of the agreement
that just says to me that they're not
giving him what he wants now a wall
street journal story said that uh musk
had stated he needs the data in order to
secure financing i'm wondering if the
people backing this deal the 19
investors outright said we want to know
how many spam bots are on this platform
before we give this money because if it
turns out it's twice or three times or
even four times as high as twitter
remarked we're going to see our value
plummet could you imagine if you
invested a billion dollars in twitter
and then the next day they're like
here's the disclosure it's actually five
times
more spam bots there's going to be you
know how 20 the company just going to
drop by that much value so they're
saying no
i don't know exactly but it seems to me
like they're trying to stop elon musk
that makes the most sense not that elon
musk isn't trying to buy it or tim it
could be the twitter employees who want
to continue to work from home and only
want to work two hours out of the week
or whatever they're doing because
because again there's a huge disconnect
between the employees at twitter the
whole establishment that is twitter that
has used this kind of information
highway for political purposes twitter
is extremely biased it has been using
its platform for political purposes for
corporate purposes for the benefit of a
lot of powerful people who wield that
power and i think the the bigger core
issue here is that probably twitter has
something to hide that they don't want
the general public to know it could be
the number of fake accounts because
there could be a lot of governments a
lot of corporations a lot of celebrities
propping up spam bots propping up
narratives and agendas in such an
artificial way that it would shock the
entire system if people would find out
but it's fascinating and also not
surprising how the mainstream media and
you mentioned that headline is choosing
to spin it because you've given
two now really legitimate reasons why
this is on twitter's end because elon
musk is asking for information
if they give him the information and
it's under five percent then he's gonna
he'll have no excuse but to move forward
with the deal and so i just i laugh this
articles from ap it says that uh this
has led some experts to question whether
the billionaire wants to use his loud
complaints to negotiate a lower deal
price or even walk away entirely he's
asking for the information if if it is
what they say it is give it to him and
then he won't walk away yeah release it
make the internet more accountab more
accountable more transparent why should
powerful people use fake accounts in
order to promote illusions that aren't
real uh reality that's an important
aspect here because we have to
understand here governments have been
creating fake accounts to push war
narratives exactly well it's also to
manufacture consensus right and we saw
this with a report that we were talking
about a week or so ago that about half
of joe biden's followers are fake which
is hilarious right because we're almost
certain given how coherent sounding the
tweets are that joe biden is not running
that twitter account so you have
a non-president running a presidential
account being followed by a bunch of
non-followers
i don't get though why even if twitter
is admitting that it's under five
percent it's admitting there's some
number of bots why wouldn't twitter
purge any bots because if you can
identify the bots
i think they did
that so the day after the deals
announced we see progressive and
celebrity accounts drop dramatically oh
they whined about it too and libertarian
conservative skyrocketing following
count
my my
personal view of this
it is probable i'm not saying i have
evidence or anything i think what may be
happening is that twitter often talks
about the health of the conversation
there's that there's there's a i forgot
it's it's there's a law on the internet
that any sufficiently unmoderated
platform will
become right-wing i think twitter was
becoming dominated by the right
so twitter intervened and started
suppressing right-wing voices and
creating fake accounts to make it seem
like the left was more prominent than it
was
that's my that's my that's my thought on
what may be because then the day after
the deals announced it just flips
there's and they said it was organic
there's no way katy perry's 200 000
follower loss or whatever mate it makes
no sense people are like i'm a follower
katy perry but now that elon musk might
buy the platform i'm out i don't buy it
no and you got how many more followers
in three days 100k 100k they were
unbanning people they were they were
unbending people had been long since
banned so i think they were manipulating
something let me let me read what
twitter wrote because we have this over
the daily mail it says quote
twitter has and will continue to
cooperatively share information with mr
musk to consummate this the transaction
in accordance with the terms of the
merger agreement we believe this
agreement is in the best interest of the
shareholders we intend to close the
transaction blah blah blah that'll be
the first sentence
twitter has and will continue to
cooperatively share information
notably absent from that statement was
we have complied with mr musk's request
to provide the data requested to help
facilitate the transaction
that statement as they publish it says
to me they're denying elon musk the
information and they're using weasel
words trying legalese to make it seem
like they're actually complying lawyer
talk i hate lawyer talking i hate people
who talk in these kind of weird vague
terms because you know they're up to
something they're trying to be nefarious
in some kind of way and and again musk
is claiming here that they're
withholding the data that this is clear
material breach and there's a one
billion dollar clause whoever walks away
from this deal is going to have to pay
for so uh this is going to be very
interesting i think this is going to go
to court i don't see any of these kind
of companies walking away i see a lot of
posturing because i do think the the
scary things in the closet of twitter
are absolutely terrifying and if we did
find out what was happening i i think
people's jaws would just drop to the
floor because there is a lot of
potential it is ripe for abuse it has
been abused what we know publicly
probably is still just scratching the
surface to the bigger agendas and the
bigger uh games that are being played
that we don't even know about there was
a report back and i think 2012 leaked
information showing that the us air
force was trying to buy sock puppet
accounts
so that they could use them in foreign
countries to create the perception of
popular narratives
so if you look at countries it is
believed that they were doing this in
libya i remember during the arab spring
particularly during libya it was
interesting because some of my hacker
buddies said how come so many libyans
speak north american dialect english
on twitter they were noticing and the
response was many of these people who
are on twitter are on twitter because
they were western educated before going
back to twitter which makes sense yeah
one of the first countries that started
doing this is israel they started openly
talking about this this was in the early
2000s there was mainstream news articles
about literal government israeli
employees that were sitting there behind
the computer sending out particular
narratives sending out particular
arguments and also cass sunstein obama's
information star even talked about how
he is going to be
utilizing the internet as a way to make
people look crazy who criticize the
government create fake accounts to
promote fake theories in order to
destroy any legitimate criticism of
government cass sunstein obama's
information czar look that up this is i
remember confronting cass onstein
one-on-one face-to-face about this and
he said i never wrote this i never did
this the the document literally has his
name it's it's published in
peer-reviewed journals uh and they were
lying through their teeth they were
talking about these and this in the
obama era what are they doing now man
you can only imagine so if let's operate
on the belief that twitter is trying to
kill the deal with elon musk do you
think it would be because they are
trying to hide what would be revealed if
it went to elon musk or because they
want to continue to control the
narrative on twitter why not both or
both yeah or they just don't want to
work i want you to pick one because elon
musk wants people to work wants people
to come into the office he's going to
change the culture and it could be that
these employees are like
crazy you saw what elon
said to tesla the other last week or
whatever that everybody has to come in
for a minimum of 40 hours
otherwise we'll assume you've resigned
i'm sure all the twitter employees saw
that and immediately started screaming
and crying and rolling on the floor we
have to work i feel unsafe here this
doesn't work no he said if you want to
he said if you want to work from home
you have to also work from the office
for a minimum of 40 hours a week so the
suggestion being any overtime you can do
at home but this this is a big story i
mean i mean elon musk uses twitter in a
very specific way now twitter is
claiming that there's only five percent
uh accounts on that entire platform that
are fake that are spam accounts that are
propaganda government accounts corporate
accounts whatever it is
musk is claiming that it's over 50 now
that's a huge number that's going to
change the evaluation of twitter but
also make people think maybe what i'm
seeing online maybe what i'm seeing in
the algorithms isn't really reality and
the way that elon musk has been
harnessing twitter recently is
absolutely amazing i've been critical of
him with neurolink artificial
intelligence him trying to connect human
brains to the internet but when he when
he called out the doj for not leaking
the epstein-galen list holy cow did he
send an important message to the power
establishment that he's not playing and
he's willing to reveal information to
the general public that would open
people's eyes about what really happens
in behind the true seat of power ladies
and gentlemen i would like to take you
into a time machine to the year of 2012.
rs technica reports
reddit founders made hundreds of fake
profiles so site looked popular in its
early days reddit was built on lies sure
lots of code but some lies here's how it
works you make a social media platform
but nobody's using it
you then need to convince people it is a
place to communicate and share ideas so
what do you do
you operate hundreds of fake accounts
and whenever you get one person to join
you respond to them you upload them you
follow them they all of a sudden feel
like wow
i'm i'm getting a lot of engagement on
this platform imagine this
you create a social media app
you market it to high schoolers
when they sign up you give them a
thousand or two thousand fake followers
those high schoolers are not going to go
to all their friends and be like i got 2
000 followers on on luke luke chat and
they're going to be like you have 2 000
followers yeah because i'm famous and
then these other kids are going to be
like i want to be on luke chat and be
famous they all start signing up you
gotta talk about bill gates only you
give them all fake followers then
they're gonna be you're still doing tick
tock dude i've got 10 000 followers on
loop chat and they'll start switching
over and you will fake the community
that's what these companies do that's
the low level that's that's a small
level of what they're doing what
governments are doing it's even far more
sinister far more complicated especially
when it comes to galvanizing people's
political opinions because when you're
able to show
a majority of people that this is what
the herd thinks this is what the herd is
people are going to go along with ideas
if they think a lot of other people
believe them and you could do that
politically you could you could do that
socially you could do that with culture
and i think that has been slowly
happening ever since social media
started to be used because we're talking
about just a few years ago it was it was
it was declassified it came out that
that facebook was talking about
engineering people's emotions through
their algorithm they were experimenting
on it exactly that were unsuspecting
people that weren't participating in a
project didn't know they were
participating in a project but they were
testing if they can make people sad if
they can make people happy that is
god-like power and authority that is
absolutely unaccountable crazy this is
what what facebook was doing years and
years ago what's twitter doing right now
with with it's information highway i
mean man it
you
i don't think no one's
you know facebook their their algorithm
knows when you go to the bathroom yep
they know when you poop
they know your friends they don't even
have facebook twitter makes me sad
already yep i don't know if they have to
do an algorithm to make me sad twitter
already makes me sad and i cannot look
at you because i just get a pregnant
bill gates looking back at me
he's making eye contact with you right
now pay attention
but that's technically not pregnant bill
gates
that's just bill gates as well no we put
his face on there i know i know i know
it's just his gun
but it was a picture of him with a big
belly in the blue shirt what happens
when you eat fake it's looking sweet
right now
that's why we like he tweeted this image
uh not this image exactly but but
pregnant so he's he's he's playing and
again bill gates is attacking him
through secret organizations uh and
nonprofit organizations that are trying
to also pressure twitter and advertisers
to make sure that that they're going to
pull their money if elon musk does buy
it there's a lot of things that could
happen with elon here because if if
let's say 50 of the accounts are fake
he's going to be laughed at like oh they
got the best of him they stole money
from him and twitter's going to lose
popularity because people are going to
be like no one's using it so so this is
an important this is make it or break it
when it comes to twitter so elon musk is
making a very big move here a lot of
money uh he's putting his money where
his mouth is will twitter give the
information
give up the data that's another question
that we need to answer thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you